okay it is not too late to book that
summer trip and it turns out if you do
wait prices might look a little better
but it's certainly not as cheap to
travel as it once was
no matter how you travel it's going to
cost you this summer is up about 18
for domestic travel compared to this
time in 2018 that's an extra 60 dollars
more per ticket according to hailey berg
an economist from hopper a popular app
that specializes in travel deals she
says although some airfare is sky high
prices are slowly coming down we expect
airfare to start falling off actually
we're already seeing that airfare is
down about 30 dollars from its peak just
a few weeks ago demand for travel
increases until about june but then
slows down as we head into july and
august travelers can actually expect to
save some money on airfare if they can
wait and travel in late august or even
september and october however airbnb
prices are up more than 11 percent this
year the average hotel cost was nearly
171 dollars a night in may 40 dollars
more than a year ago and rental cars
have soared 70 percent during the
pandemic
so if you are looking to travel still
here's berg's best advice number one tip
if you're planning to travel this summer
is to be flexible if you can travel in
late august you can save about a hundred
and twenty dollars per round trip ticket
on airfare
and as much as a hundred dollars for a
three-night stay at a hotel
as for what's really popular right now
travel experts say those all inclusive
vacations to central america and the
caribbean are the hot ticket items stick
around